the biggest names in gaming will all
collide soon at e3 and arguably the
biggest name EA will have a bunch of new
games to show off they include yearly
installments of the sports titles a few
big sequels plenty of new DLC content
and maybe even a couple of surprises
we'll get all the details in just a
second but if you're excited for e3 and
one keep up with the avalanche of news
that will definitely come out of it
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss a single announcement
probably EA's biggest game that they'll
have to show off this year is Star Wars
Battlefront 2 the sequel to 2015's
exciting if slightly bare-bones shooter
in addition to new weapons ships and
maps EA is making a big effort to create
a decent story campaign this time around
and possible come on with the plot
revolving around imperial troops revenge
on the rebel forces will hopefully get
to see some gameplay footage of the
single-player mode at this year's e3
with Forza horizon 3 dominating the
arcade racer market lately EA is looking
to take the crown back with their fresh
from the oven announcement of Need for
Speed payback the new game will take
place in the fictional fortune valley
which is about as blatant of Vegas
reference as you can get and will
attempt to fulfill everyone's action
driving fantasies it looks like cop
chases and vehicle customization will
return but the annoying always online
requirement from the previous game won't
need for speed payback will be playable
at e3 this year so expect even more
details to come flooding in very soon
the guys over at dice have been chugging
away at battlefield ones post release
content and the games upcoming expansion
in the name of the Czar will be featured
at this year's e3 the add-on pack
focuses on world war once Eastern Front
giving players control the Russian army
and will include four brand-new Maps
plenty of historical weapons and a slew
of new vehicles look for it to be
released sometime this summer
they say that in life the only things
that are certain are death taxes and ei
sports games and this year is no
different
EA will be showing off their yearly
installments of FIFA Madden and NBA live
at e3 which won't be too big of a
surprise to anyone however according to
the press release the games mobile
versions will also be on display as well
as a switch version of FIFA 18 that
they're claiming will be the most
immersive social and authentic sports
game ever created for Nintendo players
come June 10th
we'll see how accurate that is speaking
of long-running franchises EA will once
again bring the sims to e3
again there are few surprises when it
comes to the sims 4 and will most likely
see some new expansion content typical
of the series but EA is also looking to
capitalize on a huge market with their
new mobile version the sims mobile will
offer the full Sims experience from
creating your sim to building their
house to maintain their relationships
it'll all be there at e3 right in your
pocket and finally it's time to
speculate on some games that EA might
surprise us with we do know that there
have been rumors going around about a
new IP from the Mass Effect developers
Bioware some are reporting that the game
currently codenamed Dylan will probably
be some kind of MMO style shooter in the
same vein as both destiny and the
division and that the scale of the game
is bigger than anything Bioware has done
before according to the recent earnings
call we might have to wait until 2019
until Dylan is released but that's fine
just as long as they come up with a
better name by then also call me crazy
but I don't think battlefront 2 will be
the only Star Wars game ea will show a
handful of developers including Visceral
Games and respawn entertainment are
currently working on Star Wars projects
and despite them all being under wraps
until now I think it's fair to say we
can all expect a small teaser trailer
for at least one of the games
so there's a a in the nutshell for this
year's e3 some high-profile games some
casual games mixing with some sports
titles and a sprinkling of Star Wars and
Bioware rumors EA has a history of
playing it safe during their press
conferences so we can only hope that
they'll find a way to surprise us all to
keep up with all of our e3 coverage next
week make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and if you're on the go
download the game spot now app for your
I can stories of the day
[Music]